well mark welcome back to Stanford and
from one Midwestern to another we're
honored to have you here
great thank you thanks everybody so I'd
like to begin by exploring your intense
intellectual curiosity recent wired
article profiled your library and
instead of it being in your home it's
actually in the lobby of a 16z so if you
unpack for us why you put it in a place
open to visitors as opposed to your home
yeah well two reasons one is if you've
been to other venture capital offices
they look a little bit like insurance
companies it's all tombstones of
long-dead companies that they sold or
took public once-upon-a-time so we just
thought that was kind of depressing so
we decided to do something different so
that the the message that we're trying
to send with the library it's a very
deliberate message kind of go it goes as
follows which is the great thing about
the valley especially in our time is the
sense of newness in the sense of the
future and the sense of audacity that
there are radical new ideas and that
there are new people that come to the
valley all the time and can pursue
things that had never been done before
so very future-oriented and that you
know is an enormous strength Elon Musk
you know I talked about this kind of
most vividly he describes he says it's
you says you always want to thank for
first principles you want to kind of not
take any received wisdom from the past
instead you want to thank from scratch
and he makes area method assumptions in
the past may no longer be true and so if
you rethink things from scratch you can
reach different conclusions and do
things differently than could have been
done before and I think there's a huge
strength to that I think there's also a
big kind of problem with that or it's an
incomplete theory which is there are
also thousands of years of history in
which lots and lots of very smart people
worked very hard and ran all kinds of
experiments on inventing new
technologies or creating new businesses
or new ways to manage or new ways to
lead or you know all kinds of things and
they ran all these experiments they ran
these experiments throughout their
entire lives at some point somebody put
them down in a book and for you know
very little money and for a few hours of
time you can literally
learn from somebody's accumulated
experience and I think there's just
there is so much more to learn from the
past than I think that I think that we
often realize and so I you know you I
think you could productively spend
literally all your time all your life
just reading the experiences of great
people who come before and I think you
learn every time so speaking of history
one of the significant elements in that
library are the history of Hollywood and
I'm curious why that fascinates you and
what parallels if any you might see to
the development Silicon Valley yeah so
how you know in a lot of ways Hollywood
is very unlike the valley you know
probably the biggest difference is you
know in the valley if you say that
somebody startup is just all story and
no substance you know they it's a very
offensive thing to say and Hollywood
they take that as a huge compliment
because the whole point is to tell a
great story
and so they view that as a clean win
there's another big difference actually
which I find very very instructive to
think about which is you know we people
the valley whiff and think our lives are
hard or it's hard to start these
companies or it's hard to hard to you
know compete for the business
Hollywood is much more difficult it's a
much more actually like hardcore
competitive even vicious business
environment and so it's always good I
think to have perspective of people who
have it harder and than we do and still
managed to pull things off and I think
that's true of of the big successes in
Hollywood the thing that they have in
common is their you know we we we attack
and they an entertainment are the two
big original California industries right
we think between between the two
industries we kind of embody the spirit
of California and the spirit of the West
you know in the u.s. you know what's the
point of time there's a Gold Rush then
we pulled out all the gold and we're
like okay now we've got to make some new
gold and we make it through technology
and they make it through storytelling
but very similar entrepreneurial
personalities you know very lots and
lots of people you know up here
everybody's going to startup idea down
there everybody's got a screenplay lots
lots of people come from all over the
country migrated in almost everybody
from out of town people have a real
sense of what great is you know one of
the things about the valley that I think
is amazing is you it's impossible via
the valley not have a sense of what a
great technology company is because you
just think you give your nose rubbed in
it all the time it's like there's go
okay all right that's you know that's
the bar in Hollywood you know and for
what they do is the same thing you know
they made they made everything from
Casablanca to Star Wars you know all the
way up to you know all the great movies
today and and so it's just an incredibly
high quality high caliber high achieving
culture incredibly energetic people and
you know between these two industries
you know California is I think the sixth
largest economy in the world as a
standalone if it were a standalone
country it would be the sixth largest
economy in the world and I think we you
know we are the two industries that
power that so as you think about being a
venture capitalist you're taking a lot
of information from a lot of different
companies different trends this seems to
be to be a parallel to how you approach
learning picking in a wide variety of
history and other other elements from
books and stuff how do you think about
learning how do you go about like
actually figuring out what you want to
focus on and develop yeah so there's
part of what we do so the way the way
the way of modern venture firms work is
kind of strange interesting so we get
inbound pitches so we get inbound
2000 pitches a year from qualified
referred entrepreneurs so kind of some
you know somebody who's kind of hit the
basic criteria haven't been able to
network in the valley and been able to
connect to somebody we know and so you
know it's a very qualified set of
founders so we see 2,000 year and so a
lot of it is just meeting with all those
founders and like trying to survive the
tsunami right it's like I read you know
there's all these books there's this
great book a great book I disagree with
the book but it's it's a very
well-written book called the rise and
fall of American growth by an economist
named Robert Gordon he says basically
innovation is over and all the great
ideas have been taken and like from here
on out it's just you know just
everything's gonna get boring there's no
new fundamental technological
breakthroughs on the horizon and like I
would I would I would some days it would
be a relief if that were true because
you know out here we're just drowning in
it right it's just this this constant
tsunami of new ideas and new thinking
and new people you know with new
thinking and so a lot of it is just
being in that firehose that's part of it
and then like I said I'd try to
complement that by trying to be trying
to be proactive and so one is trying to
explore new areas of science in
particular and there I think some very
interesting new areas of science right
now many many of which are happening
right here at Stanford and then the
other is it history I always go back to
history
and always go back to try to understand
okay when you had you know a funny book
an example self-driving cars right so
self-driving cars are like a you know
fundamental advance in computer
technology there are fundamental advance
in the transportation industry they're
obviously going to be a very big very
big impact on the automotive industry
which is a very big global production
industry consumer industry it's like
okay well what happened you know the
thing about the impact electric cars
well let's start by understanding what
were the impact of cars right and they
were very very interesting lessons from
how cars rolled out that I think can be
applied 100 years later to figuring out
some of the some of the both the issues
and the opportunities with self arriving
cars and so I try to go back and look
for the patterns that can kind of be
more helpful in predicting the future
speaking of science backstage you
mentioned that at this point in our
history ninety percent of the scientists
that have ever existed and engineers
live right now and kind of live and are
working today but 90 percent of all
scientists or 80 or 90 percent I think
90 percent of all scientists and
engineers who have ever lived or lived
and working today so how do you think
what is that imply for Humanity going
for the next two decades in the next
century well this is why I'm such a
gigantic bull on future innovation but
so there's two basic theories the Gordan
theory is basically it's a it's a
question of low-hanging fruit and so
electrical power was looking at fruit
steam engine was low hanging fruit you
know electromagnetic waves for
low-hanging fruit and from here on out
everything gets much more complex and so
it's just it's harder you're putting
more diminishing returns you're climbing
climbing higher and higher putting more
more effort in for for less results and
and actually by the way what Gordon
points do that actually justifies that
point of view is measured productivity
growth across the economy is quite low
right and so if there were right because
it's basically there's two arguments
critics of technology basically make two
arguments one is there's no innovation
there's a productivity growth and the
other is there's so much innovation that
it's going to destroy all the jobs right
and what's important to realize is
they're diametrically opposed arguments
right they can't both they literally
factually logically can't both be true
either you have super low productivity
growth and nothing changes right on one
side of the argument or if you have
super high productivity growth through
technological change and everything
changes but you they can't they can't be
reconciled they can't they can't both be
true however there is one way they
actually can both feature which is where
things get really interesting which is
they vary by industry right and so I
actually think this is the part of his
argument that I agree with which is that
there are industries like technology
consumer electronics media
as examples where there's extremely
rapid productivity growth of
technological adoption and then there
are other industries like health care
education law government where there's
very little technological adoption and
very little productivity improvement and
so one of the things we try to do is to
try to kind of navigate through the
differences industry by industry and try
to kind of understand how to how to
apply the technology particularly in the
areas that where it hasn't been applied
before to the point of jobs in our
economy you know one of the main
criticisms of self-driving cars in the
future is you know it's five million
truckers all around the America that the
role of them in the economy may diminish
you know we see companies like Facebook
and Twitter compared to their equivalent
market capitalization companies in the
past decades having far fewer employees
so you have the mindset that the
employment peers will actually increase
as technology proliferate and why do you
think that well so there's an argument
from logic which is sort of the you know
the doctrine of free trade
specialization of Labor it's kind of
well-established an economic theory why
that would be true then there's
observation by history which is we're
sitting here today after 300 years of
technological change and there are more
jobs in the world than ever before
right there are more jobs in the u.s.
today than ever before they're more jobs
are the world than ever before there are
more people who are employed by the way
income levels have never been higher
right 404 all of our issues with
stagnation of income overall income
levels across the entire population of
the world or at an all-time high and so
if technological change were going to
cause elimination of jobs one presumes
we would have seen it by now
right again unless you kind of the
counter-argument to that is oh but
you're not taking an account like some
dramatic breakthrough and artificial
intelligence at which point I start
accusing my opponents in this argument
of just hand waving if it's so easy to
make a supergenius AI but robot why
don't you give it a shot we are looking
to try to fund it in fact I'm going to
pitch us we will we will we will we will
happily invest it may be the last
investment we ever make but it will be a
very successful one so we're totally on
board with that so you know there's
there's there's there's they're sort of
the the long-run historical view which i
think is pretty well-established then
the questions get very specific and
these are some of the questions that
have come up in this election in this
election cycle which is okay the five
million five million people involved in
driving one form or another or
transportation jobs in the u.s.
transportation delivery services
trucking things like that and you like
wow you know five million jobs seems
like a lot of jobs
and it isn't it is a lot of jobs this is
where I think people underestimate even
with our low rate of productivity growth
today
people underestimate the rate of change
in the economy that happens anyway and
so and and the thing that happens there
is that what gets reported are always
headline numbers and the headline
numbers are always the net numbers and
so any given month it'll report it just
came out I think up two days ago it's
like last month or like I forget a
hundred and seventy thousand new jobs or
something like that in the US and so
you're like geez like you're not
creating very many jobs how can you
possibly create five million so that's
the net number it's not the gross number
right so the gross number is much higher
both in terms of jobs destroyed and jobs
created and so the top-line number there
is every year in the US on average about
21 million jobs were destroyed and about
twenty four and a half million jobs are
created for a net ad overtime of about
three and a half million jobs a year and
so the the real answer to the how do you
replace five million jobs is we already
replace that in less than a quarter
today just this quarter today just this
calendar quarter with the technology we
already have what we're already going to
create more than five million jobs five
million gross new jobs and so change is
happening in the economy all the time
right and it's happen by the way it's
happening whether or not we like your
Trump it's happening whether or not we
have steel here somewhere else it's
happening whether or not Silicon Valley
rises or Falls like the changes the
change is just going to keep coming yeah
and then to me that you know that that
gets back to our day job and what I
think is so important to focus on which
is okay so then it's it's it's saying
okay the world is going to change the
jobs are going to change how do we set
people up to be able to take advantage
of the change right how do we have
change weren't for people how do we
expand the opportunities why education
is so important it's why of you know
financial services actually is so
important that's why it's so important
to be able to raise money for new
businesses it's why I'm so important for
people to be able to move from company
to company to be able to get new jobs
and then we can you know then the
conversation I think we ought to be
having as the next hours worth of
conversation on all the things that we
could do to have more people have access
to all the opportunity but the new
technology in many cases is creating
yeah you mentioned Robert Gordon who
else is in your intellectual diet that
you turn to when you want to think about
deep issues like change and
fundamentally how to me so I have a
little mental model of Peter Thiel of a
little simulation of Peter Thiel he
lives on my shoulder right here and I
argue with him all day long
who wins oh I always went face-to-face
is slightly slightly more challenging so
I'm a big believer it goes back to
history so I'm a big Charlie Munger
talks a lot about being able to learn
from the past he always says you want to
the way he describes it is you want to
build it basically calls it a mental
model but a build a mental model of a
person and you want to kind of try to
understand and it's hard because these
are you know the people were doing this
for are very smart people and so you
have to try to simulate people who in a
lot of cases they're smarter than you
are
we want to build a mental model and that
could be a mental model of you know in
modern times you know Steve Jobs or Jeff
Bezos or somebody Larry Page Elon Musk
we have mental model of somebody from
the past Thomas Edison JP Morgan it
could be a model of just you know
somebody you admire you know somebody a
great philosopher or religious figure
and you want to kind of construct a
model of how how they think and be able
to be very objective and fair where you
can kind of think things through from
from their standpoint and then you kind
of you have your own view on things and
then you try to run through kind of in
your head and what you know of them is
okay here are the conclusions that they
would reach and if you put enough time
into that you start to be able to have
these conversations I find sort of with
yourself if people might look at you
funny
law it's happening but you you get to
kind of engage in this dialogue and so
I'm a big believer in that you know the
three people in the valley who I do that
with most often on my shoulder Peter I
think Peter Elon Musk and Larry Page the
three of them I find push the boundaries
of what technology can do and what
Silicon Valley can do further than
anybody else I think they're the three
most audacious people I think probably
who have ever worked in the valley and
then you've got your models of you know
the great you know founders you know
Steve Jobs obvious and you know Larry
Ellison many's other folks who have
built amazing companies as entrepreneurs
and then the other one for us is the
great of the great CEOs right so Andy
Grove being kind of our base case for
that so we're always in whenever we talk
about management in our firm were always
trying to index back on okay what would
a Negro say if he were sitting here
today like good news with Andy is he was
very forceful and expressing his views
and so there's he's on the record with
most of the important topics and is a
very good kind of reference point for
thinking about those issues what I'm
struck by is you love to engage with
people who may disagree with you what's
the broader lesson here for those of us
here in Business School who
think about these things yeah so I just
think and you know it's again this is
the kind of thing where it this way in
venture capital in venture capital
venture capital is a funny business let
me say why I feel so strongly on this so
in venture capital there's two kinds of
mistakes you can make there's a mistake
of omission or there's a mistake of
commission which I invest in some
mistake most people make is I make a
mistake I make a decision I invest in a
company I lose all my money it's the
mistake everybody kind of thinks about
and then there's the mistake of omission
which is you know Mark Zuckerberg walks
in the door at venture capital firm X Y
Z in 2004 and you know like what is this
little kid doing and this idea is crazy
and for instr you know proved that this
could never work and this is ridiculous
which is what he got told by a lot of
people in the venture capital business
every highly successful VC has made
mistakes of omission really big ones of
companies that they really have the
chance to invest in they should have
invested and they didn't invest in it
turns out the mistakes of commission
don't really they matter but they don't
they don't they don't they don't scar
you for life because they just go and
fade into history the mistakes of
omission right it's an asymmetric payoff
when these companies work they work at
you know they get a thousand acts right
if you lose you lose one X if you if you
win you win a thousand X or 10,000 X and
then the other is the company's succeed
right the companies you passed on
succeed and they torture you right
because you those tortured your is no
comment I can't even bring myself to
talk about you you you know you pull up
Technium in the morning or whatever your
choice of thing is and you're just like
oh you know that would that one again
and so they just torment the hell out of
you and so so it's a hump it's a
humbling it's a humbling job
I think the same basic principle applies
to but much more broadly I think the
same principle especially for people
kind of in this ecosystem I think the
same principle applies to even people
that mentality applies to people with
kind of what you consider to be more
normal
normal careers right so in you know as
you think about having a career over
over 50 years you're going to make
basically a sequence of bats right and
you're going to make a sequence of bets
of the places you choose to go when the
people you choose to work with and
you're going to screw some of those up
and you're going to make a series of
bets and decisions for places you don't
want to go when people you don't want to
to work with and you're going to make
those mistakes on both sides you're
going to have the exact same feeling on
the other side when you didn't you know
when you're when you had the chance to
be employee number four at Google and
you didn't take it right like that that
sticks with you for a while like that's
that's that's a big that one tested to
wear on you and so I think that
mentality we called the slugging
percentage mentality which is basically
take the bat lose 1x don't take the bet
possibly miss on a thousand X like that
mentality is a very powerful mentality
if you're going to do that you have to
be kind of ruthlessly open-minded right
and then this is this is sort of the
when I sort of view is like why we make
mistakes of omission why do we do it and
I think it's almost always because we
have some theory for why something's not
going to work
and that theory you know you try to like
investigate that theory but you know the
problem with human nature you develop a
theory and you tend to want to prove it
confirmation bias right they call it and
so you know you develop an idea and then
you look for all the evidence that
supports it you ignore all the evidence
that disproves it and so you get locked
into your ideas right and then and by
the way pattern matching works against
you right because things that didn't
work in the past might work now right
and this is the problem with history
this is why a LAN focuses so much their
first principles is just because
Friendster
you know didn't we're just because like
myspace for example didn't reach
Facebook levels the scale didn't mean
the Facebook wouldn't be able to and so
you just have to be ruthlessly
open-minded you have to be constantly
willing to re-examine your assumptions
and to do that you can't get you have to
figure out a way to not get emotionally
tied to your beliefs yeah right as I
like to say there's a software term it's
called things this software term health
sandbox and there's idea of like you can
run you can basically run code like on
bare metal you can run code on the chip
or you can run code in a sandbox the
idea of a sandbox is it's a contained
environment where if the code goes bad
right if it's malware right or if it's
an AI that wakes up or whatever you can
Olivia nuke the sandbox right and
nothing bad happens I think we need to
run ideas in sandboxes right we believe
should be run in sandboxes like we
shouldn't sell fit to as much as
possible we shouldn't self-identify with
beliefs we should treat them all as sort
of more abstract objects and be willing
to pull them in think about them and
then put them back on the Shelf as
opposed to saying this is part of my
identity it's a very hard thing it's an
ego it's almost a zen-like it's a it's a
gift you have to take the ego out of
which is a very hard thing to do
absolutely when you never went to
business school you're in an audience
full of folks who obviously are in
business school what do you hope that we
leave here knowing both about the valley
and technology that you learned from
actual experience yeah so the big thing
the big thing the big thing so it all
sounds so easy from a distance it all
sounds so straightforward like the case
makes it all so clear so strategy so
strategy strategy strategy is important
strategy thinking about like okay what
are the decisions that should be made
over time is very important let it come
at particularly in terms of running
something right running a company right
make it making strategic decisions that
affect a company the strategic decisions
sound more obvious than they are and one
is there's just a lot of context at the
time that's that's missing even in the
histories it's usually missing the other
thing I think that the biggest thing
that biggest thing I find newly minted
MBAs have a hard time wrapping their
heads around is the abstract idea of
what the right thing to do is in a
business situation is all well and good
but as an actual manager in an actual
business you have other constraints in
particular you have organizational
constraints you have constraints as to
what your actual organization can do
right and those constraints have to do
with you know your employee base how
well your company's organized and run
you know your existing the existing
commitments you've made to those
employees the expectations of your
investors the expectations of your board
like you you Andy Grove had this sort of
anta growth had this sort of way that he
described it which is basically is that
as a CEOs in place basically on day one
a CEO has complete latitude to do
whatever they want on day two that's no
longer true because you've started to
make commitments to people you know
you've started to tell the board okay
here's my plan I'm going to do X you
told investors here's my plan i'ma do X
you told employees here's what we're
going to do here's the plan so then you
get as a CEO you get six months in 12
months in 18 months and 24 months in and
you change your view on strategy and you
go back to all the people and you tell
them we're going to do something
different and they'll say but you just
got done telling us the opposite last
week or last month or last quarter like
what's wrong with you right and so
basically what happens is the people who
take the idealized approach of shifting
strategies when it seems logical right
typically end up getting fired right by
either there they literally end up
getting either fired explicitly their
board will fire them or their investors
will fire them because they appear that
they're lurching a lot
the place and whiplash in the
organization or they get fired it's they
just get abandoned right like the
employees and the investors all get a
vote and they get to leave and they quit
but I'll have this conversation
sometimes the founders I'm like that's
all well and good but like look around
you you know you're going to be sitting
here by yourself right like how do you
feel about that right with this big new
decision that you think you're going to
make and so the real-world constraints
are very are very are very intense and
they're very context specific to that
company at that moment in time and kind
of how it got to where it got to now the
response to that Andy's response to that
was very crisp and solid which was
basically literally said this he's like
well okay like if the next guy is going
to come in here it's going to do all
these decisions like why don't why don't
we just go outside and come right back
in through the door and we'll just go
ahead and we'll just breach all the all
the old commitments and we'll just we'll
do the clearly right thing and so the
answer to the you know you're the leader
you're responsible for it the answer has
to be you know it you have to be able to
work your way through it you have to be
able to break the glass to be able to do
that it's just that's much harder and
riskier than it seems from the outside
speaking of context and leadership you
ran a very successful company with
technical employees and now you run a
very successful VC with a lot of
partners who were successful
entrepreneurs in their own right what
are the differences in leadership you
have to display in both those
environments that you've learned to
balance I guess yeah so the big thing
Syria is weighing in Siri has opinions
on management you're in the front row so
so the big thing as an operator what I
always found as an operator it's like a
90/10 thing where you're spending 90% of
your time making decisions like 90% of
the time you're sitting there and like
customers and issues and you're getting
you know employer you know product
reviews and employee feedback and you're
making hiring decisions firing decisions
market expansion decisions financial
decisions and so it's just I don't any
series of decisions all day long and
then you get maybe 10% of your time to
sit and think right if you're lucky and
if you're disciplined you kind of carve
out 10% you kind of think and read and
get caught up on kind of your own your
own theories on things and you you kind
of have to do that because these markets
tend to be brutally competitive and if
you if you just sit around thinking like
you your company's not going to go
anywhere as an investor and anybody
who's been an investor will tell you if
you take that approach to investing
you'll blow yourself to bits right if
your approach to investing is 90 percent
action 10 percent thought
right then you're like every other smell
in the stock market you're just turning
through stocks and you're gonna you're
gonna ultimately you know is a stock
market investor you're going to do
terribly because you're going to turn
your portfolio
it's a VC you're just going to blow
yourself to bits you'll do the first ten
deals and that's it and they'll fail and
you're done your career is over and so a
bias transaction as an investor is a
very dangerous thing a very generally
very bad thing and so the great VCS and
the great by the way
great VCS the great public market
managers the great hedge fund managers
you know anybody with long term horizon
they seem to spend you know 90% of their
time thinking and thinking it arguing
right there's thinking and then there's
the actual process of like all the
people around you have it to try to
convince them of your crazy idea so the
arguing part ends up dominating so 90%
of your time arguing and then 10% of
your time or maybe even less like making
decisions like one of things we ask
ourselves like how many decisions a year
do we make that actually matter and it's
probably 20 you know it's probably the
new investments we make which is about
twenty a year and those are probably
that's probably it there's lots of
things we advise on and help with but
the decisions we make it's probably two
a month like it max and so it's a it's a
it's a radically different balance of
time by the way if you've been an
operating job it sounds very appealing
because you don't have to sit there all
day long and you know be involved in
this activity and you get all this time
to think and read and talk to people and
it sounds great except a lot of
operators are highly right action
oriented and their entire success in
their career has come from taking action
right crisply and aggressively and so a
lot of operators can't make the jump to
ever being an investor because it's just
you frustrating right six months in
there just like crawling the walls right
like I'm not like they'll go on the end
of the day and they're literally like I
didn't do anything today right nothing
like this day was a total write-off I
made no decisions right and you know
that's true of 28 out of the 30 days
kind of by definition and so I'd say
like most exciting most investors can't
make the jump to operator because they
would turn into a little puddle the
plasma under their desk most most
operators can't become investors because
they can't deal with the frustration of
not taking the action and so we're
trying to straddle it you know somewhere
in the middle we have this bit this is
the speech I give when we when we only
have former founders of CEOs as GPS at
our firm
so they've we have all been through this
position and this is the little speech
that I give every time and they all tell
me yep you got it I understand and then
six months later they're like oh I see
so you mentioned crazy ideas what are
some of those crazy ideas that you guys
are banding around in the 816 Z offices
that you think will define the future
that's looking valiant tech here yeah so
we we go the way we sort of go is it was
also extremists on think about ideas
which is generally like if people smart
people the industry are going to have
figured out everything that's going to
happen next five or ten years like it's
it's actually one of the things like I
be Peter but Peter my little argument
with my shoulder Peter Peter talks a lot
about secrets and he talks about secrets
being something that you know or believe
that that other people either don't know
or don't believe actually think like
over a five or ten year period they're
actually aren't very many secrets like
most of the good ideas are already kind
of obvious by the way they've probably
been tried before they probably failed
but the time is going to come where
they're going to work and so you know we
in the industry you know iPad is a
spectacular new idea except it wasn't a
new idea Apple had something called the
Newton 20 years earlier that was
basically the same thing it failed been
it worked in 2009 you know so tablet
computing was not a new idea just it
happened to take 20 years to get it to
work but for that entire 20 year period
it did look like a good new idea so most
of the good ideas are kind of out there
they're circulating or they're running
by the way they're running in labs you
know over here in the engineering
department like they're already up and
running as prototypes and and and grad
students are working on them and so I so
that part of it is not like and we swim
in that world and try to understand it
and all that but like it's not that
there are huge discovered ideas in it
with a short term timeframe so I think
we spend a lot more of our time on the
idea side trying to think okay 10 plus
years out right sort of take the extreme
view right if like okay it's sort of the
court of adventure philosophy which is
forget whether or not it will work ask
the question about what if it did work
and then kind of push that question out
as far as you can right
so I mentioned self-driving cars so
let's just assume for a moment that
self-driving cars actually work okay
what are the consequences of that right
well for example one consequence is you
know potentially it cars changed our
idea of geography right before cars
everybody has used to have to live in
the city cars created the idea of the
suburb right because you could you could
actually commute you know we all sit
here you know 80 years later wishing
that nobody had thought of that because
commutes are horrible right the number
one
correlator to job satisfaction is can be
a time right and so you've got you know
you see this every day you're sitting
there in traffic you know sitting there
next to these everybody has the same
epiphany it's like it's 8:00 in the
morning I'm sitting there and I'm like
okay I'm sitting there's a car over
there with one person there's a car over
here with one person and I'm sitting
here alone like somebody really should
come up with a carpooling admin every
morning right every driver has that idea
and yet we all still commute right in
our cars and said we all hate it and so
and it's all wasted time but you know we
have people at our companies now who
commute two or three hours a day and
it's just completely waste of time I
mean now they can play pokemon go right
well they drive but that has that has
other issues so then you say okay
self-driving cars well self-driving cars
maybe you can reclaim all that time
right maybe you can reclaim all the
commute time right and so maybe all of a
sudden you can have the idea that maybe
an hour-long commute is actually a big
perk right because instead of driving
what if you're instead of having to sit
and focus and lurch through traffic what
if your car is a rolling living room
right and what if you get to spend that
hour playing with your kid or reading
you know reading reading the news or
watching TV or actually working right
because you don't feel worried about
driving or what if you know what if you
have different kinds of cars what if
some cars are rolling offices what if
other cars are rolling you know bit but
by the way I can sleep
take a nap I can sleep I can sleep for
six hours at home get the car asleep for
another hour and a half on my way to
work be all set right
and so in that version of the world all
of a sudden maybe suburbs like are and
maybe now we go to excerpts right maybe
now geography becomes actually much more
tractable and we can have these urban
environments get much much larger right
and so we're trying then we're trying to
think okay then back from that okay what
would be the consequences of that right
will be the consequences of that in
terms of how these companies get built
you know what would be the
infrastructure that has to get built to
support that kind of thing right what
are the what are the kind of early
signals that kind of show that that kind
of thing is either starting to happen or
not and try to kind of chart it at least
some view of how the future will unfold
and so yeah so you mentioned a lot of us
have great ideas we want to execute on
you've also noted that capital is
abundant and opportunities are scarce
yeah and I think venture capital is only
a 50 billion dollar industry amongst a
multi trillion dollar economy what do
you make of the different investment
choices being a bit larger companies
face what's happening here yeah so this
is the big thing this is the big thing
this is the big thing I think about the
about tech so everybody
so once upon a time we had a tech bubble
some of you may have noticed I read
about it it was a it was followed by a
catastrophic crash in 2000 it was an
actual bubble the numbers are very clear
on that
in there's about four years of nuclear
winter we're very little happen and then
starting in 2004 tech started to work
again and between 2004 and today it's
just been constant commentary of bubble
bubble bubble 2.0 you know all the way
up and to the right as Tech has worked
constant you know screaming a bubble up
to and including the chairman of the
Federal Reserve Janet Yellen has
developed a theory the text in a bubble
which is we really appreciate out here I
think she might have slightly larger
issues to deal with so and and by the
way like it with imminent predictions of
a crash right which which hasn't
happened right and it's every six months
imminent predictions of a crash no crash
and it might actually be starting to
give up on this which ironically would
probably be the sign of an actual bubble
in any event the result of all that is
exactly what you said so all of New Tech
in the US all of new tech venture
capital growth investing all of what we
would consider to be what Silicon Valley
does total capital in is about fifty
billion dollars a year and again sounds
like a big number is a big number an
absolute basis it's a drop in the bucket
from a national or global standpoint
right so the US economy ggp the US
economy as I know it's like six trillion
dollars or something like that and then
just look at financial assets the the
there's I think the numbers now it's
like 14 trillion dollars of negative
yielding government debt in the world
right so bonds that people have to pay
for the privilege of holding and then
and then just even look in corporate
America this year alone corporate
America will disgorge more than a
trillion dollars of cash back to
shareholders right as I just think about
this way like a trillion dollars of cash
is coming out of the fortune 500 that
literally can't figure out anything to
do with the cash other than give it back
right anything productive to do with it
so they give it back dividends and
buybacks so trillion dollars comes out
and then 50 billion basically call it of
that goes back and attack where does the
other 950 billion go right into negative
yielding bonds
and so which is what to me it's like
okay everybody's like why are interest
rates so low like I think interest rates
are so low for a fundamental reason
which is the world is awash in capital
right basically the 20th century worked
the 20th century created enormous
amounts of wealth all around the world
and that process continues and and now
that money is all out there sitting in
these giant pools primarily people's
retirement savings right these huge
pensions are these big sovereign wealth
funds that basically represent people's
future retirement and that money all
needs to earn a return of six or seven
or eight percent a year to pay for
everybody's old age and that money is
seeking out investment opportunities and
it can put 50 billion into tech and then
where else is it going to go and so I
don't think there's a tech bubble I
think there's a massive tech bust right
I think we're running a critical
shortage of new technology in the world
and I think you can view that through a
technological lens in productivity
growth but I think you can also view
that on a financial lens which is
they're literally are not we as a
society cannot come up with enough
places to productively to play capital
and this this is the thing like this
just seems completely bizarre like do we
have any problems yes we do right we've
got like massive education problems
massive health care problems we've got
many the big problems all over the world
still to this day funding problems are
funny we used to have a massive global
hunger problem right now of course we
have a massive global obesity problem
good news people are starving to death
as much anymore bad news now everybody's
going to die of diabetes and heart
attacks right so now we have but like
it's still a problem so now we have a
big problem on the other side and so
we've got the money right look through
most of recorded history you'd have
these problems and you wouldn't be able
to fund an answer to them right so we've
got the money we can we can fund the
answers we've got the problems we know
what we have to go do it's the process
in the middle that's kind of all screwed
up and so that's where I just think like
a tax on Silicon Valley of like being
bad and innovation or whatever kind of
beside the point even if you're right
even if even if the value even the
critics are alright in tech and Silicon
Valley is a joke and it's all just a
bunch of photo sharing apps and like
self-driving cars will never happen and
we're all smoking around exhaust out
here it's like okay so then what right
if like if we suck okay fine like who
else like who else is going to do it by
the way the Chinese are going for it but
again they're again the dollars you know
there's a big tech investment boom
happening in China but again the
absolute dollars just aren't that big
roll
- even the Chinese economy much less our
economy and so I think that's the it's a
it's a tech depression more than it's a
more than it's a more than a so tech
bubble is that risk aversion on the
parts of investors or is it rational
behavior well it's a combination it's a
bunch of factors I think it's it's like
for sure I think we've been in a risk I
think we've been in a risk-averse equity
market since the 2000 crash which is
sort of if you look at kind of the
history of crashes and what happens
after right people people fight the last
the last war and so what we know from
2000 is the stocks crash so everybody's
constantly fearful like the headlines
are always the markets about to crash
like all the way up and then since 2008
on top of that we now have a massive
aversion to debt right we're incredibly
scared about scared about debt we're
scared about real estate it's really
interesting like you talked to like our
investors are some of these big you know
the Stanford endowment here manages like
twenty five billion dollars and if you
talk to folks like the guys who run the
Stanford endowment not them specifically
but that that that class of people is
just like they they literally they go
through okay here are all the things we
can invest in like public equities you
know terrible performance mm crash
horrible bonds you know we just had a
financial crisis bonds are largely
unsafe and don't yield anything anyway
real estate blew up in 2008 you know
that could blow up at any moment
commodities you know it looked like oil
was going to go to the moon now it looks
like the world of Washington oil glut
the Saudis are dumping on the market at
any price
okay so can't invest in commodities you
know they go through you know hedge
funds were you know activist hedge funds
were working and now they don't work
anymore and they're blowing up you know
venture capital you know we hear good
things but everybody says it's a joke so
let's you know maybe good we can only
put a small amount of money in anyway
and so they just literally like a
process of elimination it's like okay
where is the money going to go and so
it's it's this weirdly perverse like
it's like I get really pessimistic about
this because I'm like there's something
the transmission mechanism is not
working properly like somehow there's
something between the money the problem
and then the transmission mechanism to
connect the money to the problem that
involves right ideas people companies
technology right management something in
there is broken but I also get very
optimistic because it's like boy if we
could figure out how to get that
transmission mechanism working better we
could go do much bigger things and that
by the way is a very big reason for
optimism in the valley as you do have a
lot of founders in the valley now who
are going after much bigger problems
than people used to go
right like you know it it did not use to
be the case that the valley would go
after ideas like you know just what the
huge efforts not going on to go after
different areas of healthcare or
transportation as an example or even
space right you know what he was doing
with SpaceX you know they're just
inconceivable that those ideas would
have been tried twenty years ago and so
there are a group of people who do have
this view that like we can now go do
these things yeah like it sit here for
hours of course they have time for one
last question for a Q&A from the
audience and this is deeply personal to
me I know you have a 20 month old son I
have a 22 month old son how should I
raise him in the next 5-10 years to be
relevant in the 21st century can I get
back to you 20 or 25 years once we find
out how it went on our end um like I
just that I think curiosity I mean I
just think curiosity I think it's it's
it's a it's a cliche but I think it's
true which is just you know whatever the
assumptions are about how the world's
working today you know somebody kids
just get brought up
I think Douglas Adams had this whole old
line he said whatever whatever existed
before you're born is just like it's
just like you know ancient and
irrelevant whatever happens when you are
whatever happens in new technologies new
ideas happen when you're an adult when
you're a young adult or you know
exciting and fresh whenever ideas that
appear you know past age of 50 or
against the holy order of things and
it's this natural kind of human kind of
view of like you know we you know it's
weird like history is very long we show
up a bunch of stuff has happened we draw
a bunch of conclusions from that a bunch
of other stuff happens and we have a
relatively narrow window to have an
impact on that and so I think that ain't
curiosity is just really really critical
curiosity and ability to learn you know
frankly everybody has an opinion
education you know my opinion is our
education system is still dominated by
an industrial age theory of you know
we're creating cogs for a machine I mean
not luckily at places like Stanford
they're they're they're exceptions to
that but a lot of like K through 12 a
lot of that is fundamentally to get
people to work on farms or in factories
if you trace the ideas behind education
right people sitting in rows in the
classroom and somebody that's seen your
authority figure sitting in front
lecturing the whole thing that's very
kind of you know 1890 kind of era
philosophy Frederick
what's his name the mass-produced mass
production right applied to education
and so I think the thing with kids is to
try to get them to the point where
curiosity and learning is good and
exciting and fun right and it sounds
obvious and yet you know for most people
that never happens well I let me turn it
over to the audience for some questions
hi mark this is Sam
I just feel 2016 alumni I I've seen the
ecosystem for the start of VC have like
I've changed evolved significantly over
the past ten years in terms like more
entrepreneurship educational resources
cheaper resources for startups and more
like incubator startups so that probably
make the competition among the VCS like
more serious nowadays so I'm curious
about what what's your view about this
ecosystem over the next 5-10 years and
what's your what matters most to you and
just so how is to win in this world it's
like your vision your PR marketing or
your disciplines on that research and
due diligence yeah thanks right yeah so
the big thing I think from from what you
said that I agree with you that the
startup ecosystem has changed a lot and
generally in a very positive way the big
thing that's happened as you said the
big thing has happened is it's just the
education it's so much more widely
available there are now so many more
people both here in the valley and
around the world who now know how to
start a company and that maybe sounds
obvious but like it when I arrived in
the valley in 1994 like I went to the
bookstore and I tried to find a book on
how they start a tech company and like
it was a long and lonely trip through
the bookshelves like there was very
little I mean luckily Andy's Andy's book
was there but Andy's book was about how
to run Intel which it was a monopoly
I didn't couldn't really get a lot of
benefit out of that for my startup at
the time and so like the resources just
simply didn't exist right and today
you've got you know it's everything
you've got a lot of it comes out at
Stanford so like this is it's the CS 180
just the CS 183 courses Stanford the
various people have taught Peter taught
and that moment is taught like and then
the fact that those classes are not just
accessible to people at Stanford they're
accessible to people all around the
world and there are people all around
the world
right those those videos all the time
learning how to start companies and so
like the informations out and then you
have these new ecosystem kind of
participants like Y Combinator in
particular which has had this big impact
in the valley and Y Combinator is not
producing 240 startups a year in the Bay
Area out of there out of their current
program and they're they're they're
planning to wrap that up ironically for
venture capital this has all been a
tremendous blessing because this is deal
flow and so the more startups there are
you know the the pond that we fish out
of is very well stocked and so we are
super super thrilled that all these
things are happening because we get to
evaluate you know a far larger number of
startups prettier than used to be the
case I think the competition is actually
much more intense between the startups
and you actually see that like at Y
Combinator you'll see that well there
will be a company that will be super hot
in a YC class that will doing will be
doing an idea and then and then they'll
be the belle of the ball and they'll
raise money and it's all bad and then
six months later in the next class there
will be another company doing the exact
same thing and now they're the hot
company in the previous companies like
you know what the hell and that and then
they compete and then they both go they
both come to raise venture capital year
later and then we as VCS get to pick
between the two and so that's it's at
least so far it's been really really
great great for VC if you're thinking
about starting a company it therefore
really stresses an idea and again I'll
use my use my Peter Thiel and the
shoulder thing channel this through
something Peter says I think is really
relevant which is a lot of founders
think about what it takes to get the
second person in the company right the
second founder of the second engineer
right at the third person of the fourth
person he says that's no longer the
challenge like everybody wants to start
a company and so everybody can get
together two or three or four people to
start a company you said the challenge
is how do you get engineer number 20
right because engineer number 20 right
if they're in this ecosystem right they
could go start their own company right
and so how do you convince somebody to
join your company as engineer number 20
with a tiny percentage of equity right
and and not being in charge as compared
to starting their own company getting
all the equity and being in charge now
one of the things you do is you tell
them they're going to have the same
problem but then they respond to you
that you also have that problem and then
you sit there and stare at each other
awkwardly so so that that's the thing so
so what you have right now is you just
have you have you have just a very very
large number of seed funding companies
that are experiments and their
experiments on their ideas but more
importantly their experiments on who has
the will and the drive and the
horsepower right in the salesmanship and
everything else that goes into
recruiting right and so and every other
guy should Sam only gave a talk today he
said if you can wave a magic wand you
would combine a lot of these companies
together to get critical mass but
mergers between startups almost never
happen for a variety of reasons and so
so it really makes this sort of acute
this this recruiting problem is a very
acute problem by the way you think about
it then as the temptation is to think
about it as a recruiting problem which
is we have to get really good at
recruiting but it's not really that as
much as it's like okay what about my
company is going to be so spectacular
and so special and so unusual and so
distinct and differentiated that it's
going to be able to easily hire engineer
number 20 away from starting his or her
own company and so to me it basically
translates into basically we just you
have to get better like you just have to
get better you have to be able to
compete and you have to be able to win
in this really brutal initial battle the
good news is the company's coming out of
that sort of churning kind of you know
sort of you know sort of sneak fit of
competition the companies that come out
of that are really strong because they
had to be to come through it but it it
is tougher and it is the other side of
how easy it's become to start to start
the companies
Thanks and thanks mark for your time
my quick I have a question about the
international investing so I see some
top pieces like sequoias kleiner perkins
they went to china market many years ago
but in the contrast I think andreessen
horowitz
pretty much is pretty much focusing on
the US market I want to download your
point of view of expanding investment in
investing in those emerging market like
China India Southeast Asia just like to
hear about your view yeah so it's very
it's extremely tempting because there
are entrepreneurial opportunities and
great companies all over the world and
increasingly distributed right all over
the world literally and so it's very
tempting but the I'll tell you the
typical problem and then I'll tell you
the theoretical question that comes out
the other side so so the problem is to
the extent that venture capital
investing is like we understand it today
which is it's a very hands-on process of
really deeply understanding it's a
people business it's the process of very
deeply understanding the people you're
working with deeply understanding the
founders deeply understanding the
executives in the company the engineers
the management team the culture you know
it's one of the to evaluate the company
and also to help work with the company
if it's always been a hands-on business
like that right when it's worked and so
if it continues to be a hands-on
business like that then there's a
problem with Geographic remoteness right
which is you know if I'm not present in
another geography do I really know the
people well enough to be able to make
those decisions
so then what a bunch of firms have tried
to do is they then staff local teams
right but then you you have this
fundamental problem where you have this
sort of adverse selection problem where
if that local team is really good they
can easily leave and go run their own
firm right which is actually the exact
same this exact same problem I just
talked about the startups it also
applies to venture capital firms which
is like how can I get if we say we had a
really good team on the ground in China
how can I convince them to stay with us
as opposed to just they could very
easily go down the street open up their
own shop raise money there's plenty of
investors in China who want invest in
venture capital and so if they're good
they leave and start their own firm if
they're bad they stay working for me
which has its own issues and so most of
those experiments have not worked it is
very striking Sequoia in particular has
worked really well and they have built a
very good team and they figured out a
very good dynamic on that but it is a
very tough question because you have to
really dig it okay why did it work for
them and why has it not worked for so
many others if you want to think about
doing that yourself and so that that
sort of a variance oh it's a live topic
or question in the you know in the
venture ecosystem now there's the
assumption go back to first principles
the assumption underneath that is that
venture capital is a hands-on business
and should be a hands-on business the
way I've described it right and if you
even if you look at history if you look
at investment banks you know 100 years
ago they were very hands-on like this if
you look at private equity firms in the
70s you know when they were a boutique
business they were very hands-on like
this you know one point stock investing
was probably a lot like this you know
these days in a lot of fields it's not
hands-on anymore now it's fully become
computerized system ties and
computerized and so the counter-argument
to my whole theory on this the
counter-argument is I'm describing
venture capital the old-fashioned way it
shouldn't be so based on people it
should be done through algorithms right
you should be able to do quantitative
venture capital right and so you should
be able to either like open up a
crowdfunding marketplace and let the
world compete with ideas and to be able
to raise capital which is what angellist
is trying to do or you should there's
very there various firms now trying to
do quantitative venture capital you
should basically go gather all the data
you can look at everybody's college
transcripts you can look at everybody's
past career record you know their
LinkedIn connections or whatever data
you want to look at and you can assemble
a quantitative view great to predict
success or failure and invest that way
you know people are trying I would say
we haven't yet gotten to the point where
we think we figured out how to do that
again I fantasize that somebody's going
to come in and pitch us on building that
as a company and we can fund it and then
we can retire but I think like that
question of like is it really going to
continue to be that hands-on is is the
question underneath the question that
you asked and I think it's an open
question
hi my name is Sam Jackson I've
questioned about the question of capital
wash so what advice would you have for
people who have big ideas that might be
very capital-intensive and a couple
years ago I asked Elon Musk what was his
advice if someone want to start a new
SpaceX or Tesla he suggested that I
become an internet billionaire first so
I was wondering to get any other may be
easier ideas that is how he did it
um so it is actually striking it is
striking the guys yes the guys the guys
who are most prone to be like yeah the
software stuff is useless and stupid we
should be going to space travel instead
they all started doing the useless and
stupid software stuff so that that that
that is true I would like to tell you
this is a quite aware this is a question
I think this is a this is a oppose an
open question which I do think through
and a lot of people trying to think
through but it bears here's how I think
about this which is ok like there's a
well there's a well-known corporate
investing model which is GE or Honeywell
you go to one of those places or
Lockheed and they've got their big
programs and you either work through
bureaucracy to do your program or not
and that's a known that's where most of
these you know big capital intensive
things happen and then there's the
venture capital model and the venture
capital model right is sort of staged in
the capital over time right and you sort
of you its milestone based investing but
the milestones are kind of undefined and
then you're going to a new investor in
every round and so you've kind of got
this constant financing risk right which
says what if I can't raise the next
round of money and then you've got the
problem with these capital intensive
projects where it's like well I know
it's going to take a half a billion
dollars to get to market if I go raise
20 million from VCS today I have this
massive funding risk of 480 million in
the future right and then from your
standpoint can I even recruit the team
to be able to build the product because
I can't even tell them that the money
will be there and then Andreessen on
stage and told me about the 14 billion
of negative yielding government debt and
why can't I get somebody to give me the
500 billion to do the thing and so the
idea that's floating around is sort of
an idea to borrow an idea from actually
a large public infrastructure and
private infrastructure gets built which
is project finance which is basically
like the way a dam gets gets built which
is basically really like a lot of
airplanes airplane projects get run new
airplanes is basically you know unlikely
to look about like the Silicon Valley
model we're gonna have a new idea
we're also going to have milestones
unlike to Silicon Valley model we're
going to have a very very crisp
understanding of what those milestones
are right we're going to have a program
management office that's at a level of
sophistication the typical value startup
doesn't have and we're going to chart
out in detail how that money is going to
get spent what the milestones are along
the way right how the organization is
going to get built to do that and it's
going to be like it's going to be
precise like we're going to know week by
week what all the work is and all the
parts and how they fit together and
we're going to try to get to a much
higher level of predictability to build
the thing than a typical VALIC startup
would have and then in theory you could
then raise money and this is sort of
where there could be a new asset class
and call it like tech project finance
where you could basically say ok you
could go and you could raise 500 million
and the 500 million wouldn't show up in
your bank account instead enough money
to get to the first milestone Oh to show
up and then there'd be a checkpoint and
then if you hit the checkpoint you get
the money right and so the money unlocks
over time right and so then you could
think about having a sort of a tech
project finance venture fund where you
could have like you could have 20
projects like that start and then you
could assume that like 10 of them fail
along the way and get liquidated right
and just get shut down before most the
money has gone in and maybe 10 of them
work and then you know then then the
fund is big enough to fund 10 to
completion but not 20 and you kind of
play it like a venture portfolio so that
idea is kind of floating out there and
by the way this is what I'm describing
them this is kind of how Google X works
a little bit and this is how some of the
advanced R&D projects is something the
Big Valley companies operate and so that
idea is out there but it doesn't fully
exist in the form that I just described
and I think one of the real interesting
questions for the future of tech is are
we collectively going to figure out a
way to do that right because if we can't
figure out a way to do that and the
projects you're describing either have
to be these flukes right you've a
once-in-a-generation Elon Musk internet
billionaire who decides to build a space
company in a car company at the same
time because who would do that or it's
just gonna be big companies doing all
this stuff right which would be a
depressing answer mark thank you so much
for your time we appreciate you being
here good good thanks everybody